this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much to Alina and Mike and
organizers we are real joy to be here
it's my first trip to the makeup plant
science in the US I am really really
excited so before I show you some of the
phenotyping data let me explain what the
plan imaging consortium is so we are
consortium of Arkansas and mr. ebay sign
these were funded by the NSF EPSCoR
track to a program and basically we are
as a group of plant scientists who came
together convinced of the importance of
plant a tree pod phenotyping and other
imaging tools and what the project
allowed us to do is really open the
access to some from an interesting
essence hydropathy no typing and other
imaging technologies to really empower
discoveries in plan stressed biology so
I want to acknowledge some of my
colleagues dr. day there are three
scientific elite in history and two in
Arkansas in history the leads are Sylvia
Jewison jontron PI and they with brawn
and in Arkansas the leads are key an
evolving and myself and again I'll tell
you more about it this is our website
and among the things that we have done
is funded young scientists and I learned
yesterday that you are getting an
excellent one coming through
Cornell coming back to Cornell so that's
wonderful
you are going to see also here Noah for
green and Malia Jehan these are two very
talented scientists and they got some
funding from our consortium to really
develop further plans TV which is an
open source software and is really a
community resource where you can
contribute and I'm going to show you
what we have contribute to this field
okay so I'm pretty sure that
I'm preaching here to the choir is that
all of these are biotic stresses and
also of course biotic stresses present a
big challenge to agriculture and we need
better ways to measure plant performance
and these interactions the genes by
environment interaction to do that we
are are convinced and I believe top
talked already show us digital signal
typing is a very powerful tool because
you go beyond the resolution of the
human eyes to really extract all of this
important information out of these
images so let me discuss the platform
art so in Arkansas there is 50 plant
scientists throughout the state you have
here a treasure you have a new right
we are filthy and we're scattered in
five different universities so we came
together and said how can we be more
impactful so we came together and form a
virtual Center right so we call it the
plant power production and again with
NSF funding we were able to acquire this
instrument because we were really
looking for things that will empower and
do our go from the scripting science to
quantitative science and go from a very
very biased approach which is manual
phenotyping to an unbiased approach so
this is the system we acquired in Tuscon
a larger HTS from Lemna tech it has four
cameras a visible camera a fluorescence
camera an infrared camera and an
infrared camera and already talked all
those are some of the benefits of each
of these sensors and what I want to
bring to your attention is we can see no
type Arabidopsis we can see no type also
the seedling stage of many crops in this
configuration and we also have a vector
accommodates
place and route evil place so the
downside of our system is very fast in
each space here so I cannot go beyond
the before the
the state of of many crops so that's the
downside of the system we are ok so
again a little bit more detail on the
camera the visible camera again the
workhorse you can interrogate and get
information regarding size architecture
and color it with the fluorescence
camera we can have an indication of
plant health through chlorophyll
fluorescence on with the special filters
you can measure fluorescent proteins or
for example inhale roots that are
non-photosynthetic we can measure
technologies with the reinsurance camera
we can get information regarding water
content and with the infrared in this
temperature ok so again why do we like
it some buyers non-destructive federal
phenotypes can be detected and this is
one of my favorites RAW images are
permanently store and you can come up
later with a different question and
interrogate the data set now if careful
metadata is kept I think there is a lot
that can be gained by the overall
community if we deposit this data in
places where in public where Elena's and
interrogate my data I can intervene
Chris and so on and so forth
so the throughput of our system is if we
do multi well place in the order of 8000
samples per run and form or most of the
assets we do with cleansing soil between
18 and 45 plants to run an around
usually takes less than an hour so I
love the system mostly because
experiments that before it took me 6
months to get done now I get them done
in four weeks so site and also now I can
manage a lot higher number of samples
then the statistics and the robustness
of your variant groups
ok so this is my current team half of
the teams that vitamin C metabolism
which is my passion I love plant and
biochemistry of plants but the other
half of my team really does in the
piping for me for what several
universities
misery and for all of the external users
were serving this is a very talented
postdoc dr. Susan you he's the one who
has developed all of the algorithms
applications that I'm going to show you
again very talented group of students so
the plant we have the most experience
with are are shown here and I'm gonna
Olin asked me to show an example with
our abilities and one with a real call
someone will show rice today
so here my example so to show you what
we have got were one of the project we
have done in a libido space I'm gonna
show you collaborate this project with
the laboratory of dr. David Mendoza from
the University of missouri-columbia
he's an eye on omics person is into
loving made out like Sarah love you here
so he loves metals and understanding how
metals are absorbing them transporter so
what we have done in this article and in
this paper that we published recently is
really do I anomic and phenomics in the
same plant under water limitation
condition so basically here is
experiment we are germinate our
abilities in place we select the robot
seedlings with transfer goes to soil one
way we have robot seedlings
we divided them into four different arm
treatment groups and what a control
group and three ones with water
limitation conditions and we say they
plan we're phenotype every other day
of course we measure we make sure that
we are imposing water stress and in
addition to the phenotyping with the
analyzers we are also incorporating this
beautiful instrument developed by David
Kramer's laboratory and Michigan State
is called multi specs q is a
non-destructive
instrument that allows you to do the
same thing that a life for life but
instead of costing you $60,000 it goes
so again what we like it is not its
non-destructive and we see great
correlation between what the data we are
capturing this instrument and the
fluorescence data we are getting with a
scanner like that and of course the
economics person loves his icp-ms
okay so here a little bit of the images
again control and three water stress
conditions we're showing you the images
and the analysed images these all of
these data set was analyzed with the
luminaries our software that we acquired
with the instrument and as you can see
really the big changes in size of the
plant come on until you get to these
levels of water limitation so here is
the big surprise for us
so with of this is be very resilient and
you can get down up to 50 percent water
and there is no penalty in the growth of
the vegetative growth of the plant
however look at what happens to sit
below all I mean even at this level
big big drop in in CD also what we found
out we fiddle is a lot more sensitive to
water stress and vegetative growth so in
terms of the ergonomic what the beat
found is that the effect of salt is very
element and very treatment in specific
and again I know cell of do metal lovers
will bombard me with questions oh yes
I just wanted to illustrate some of the
power P okay so something that Lucy
Acosta the PhD student that did this
work knowledge is that although from the
images from the top there was no
difference in leaf area between between
these two treatments she knows that
there were more leaves here and that
were dr. Lu developed for us this
beautiful strategy to count little more
effectively and indeed and we found that
under control conditions there were more
Leafs these modules for leaf counting
has been
added to plan CV and again that's again
my I really encourage you to take
advantage of these great resource you
can apply to images that you acquire
with any system you don't have to
necessarily take it with any particular
system with its really really flexible
really good ok so again I couldn't not
talk about the starving biosynthesis so
this is a molecule that is my big
passion I work on it for the last 14
years it turns out that plants have four
different ways to get to that molecule
and I was very very fortunate to be part
of the team that at Virginia Tech
discover these pathways that start with
my inositol so since I moved to Arkansas
State my students and I now have
characterized at least one member of
each one of these gene family and when
we overexpress them and here I'm showing
you what happens when we overexpress the
first enzyme this happens to plant this
one at the same chronological age grown
under the exact same conditions this is
the highlight the high vitamin C one and
this is the one time so this is this
looking for a way to quantify this
phenotype is what what means phenotyping
I wanted to go from pretty pictures to
okay tell me how much bigger ready okay
so we at the beginning like all of you
with we did lots of manual phenotyping
and what we have done is now validated
that all of the manual phenotyping we
did are was indeed correct but now we
have new readouts of health that we
didn't have before so here I just want
to clarify this is the wild-type and
this is the high vitamin C Line and I'm
using as controls to two lines of that
of express a proton pyrophosphate laser
this line is very very famous and uses
control to this unknown
salt tolerance and also learned line so
as I told you color classification is
very powerful but we were sort of
limited with the lemon agrees approach
because we were only able to distinguish
green and yellow but not different tones
of green which is what we wanted to do
so again dr. you develop a club ekko a
color classification approach that has
given us much better resolution in
understanding so this is what happens to
well that in response to solve and the
transgenic the highest score rates don't
show these yellow in phenotype sorry I
should clarify it is not noticeable with
your naked eye okay so I'm going to
switch now to right to show your next
annex an example with right so this is
funded by the plant genome program and
it's a collaboration with the University
of nebraska-lincoln so they have we have
looked together for novel sources of
salt tolerance in rice and my main
collaborator is Harkema Valley and he
has done all of the phenotyping at the
pillar in a dirty pannikin initiation
stages and I've done the one at the
seedling stage so let me show you and
this is I don't know if Susan Lee Cindy
in the audience this is very familiar to
you because it's the right diversity
panel that Susan might push and her
collaborators develop this has been a
wonderful resource for us to find those
novel genes involving salt tolerance in
rice and important an important problem
in the world and in certainly in
Arkansas the main producer of rice in
the US so the beauty of this is it has a
core group that represents or five
different two groups of rice and of
course there is all of these genomic
information that Susan and her group
have not had made available so
phenotyping this was an obvious choice
we're going after
tissue tolerance not after
exclusion as mode of action for soul
tolerance and the very beautiful work
that High Command has done is he did all
of the all of these working at the
Australian accelerator again and develop
a pipeline for the visible images and a
pipeline for the fluorescent images I
should emphasize for the fluorescence
images a very talented undergrad in his
lab wrote this software that is also
very powerful for analysis is called
image harvest which will be against the
cost in early of plan 3 so this is
another approach of an open source
software to analyze this type of images
harkaman already has found candidate
genes and it's already validating them
and again this is this was at the
filling station here they come his
publication let me show you a little bit
what I have done at our console space in
my case with minority undergrad 14 of
them knowing nothing about science they
have come to my lab for the summer and
they have generated publication quality
data I'm very proud of okay
so hard to Mouse and the seeds we clean
them
we germinate them once we have healthy
seedlings we transfer them to this
hydroponic system this is just
calculated clay to provide support we
put this signal typing trace in these
stuff and this is where we put Yoshida
solution as a control group and two
pseudo are and we set up an identical
tray but with four so in the first
experiment we did we this was our
control group and we were providing the
salt in three different steps that we
were not seeing a robot's
phenotypes so we went a little bit more
aggressive so in all of the day I'm
gonna show you this is the black line is
our control and we made the salt in
three increments and phenotype during
the experiment so first let me show you
the result with unknown salt or land
line this is the representative images
of the line through the
just with Yosi resolution and this is
what happened this is a really a
salt-loving line our digital readouts
completely are but what the images say
and manual phenotyping also bugs what we
saw with the salt alone this is an
example of a salt tolerant line again
this line grew better than the control
and this manual single typing with this
at the end of the experiment shoot will
bust up these results and as you can
imagine most of the lines were false
sensitive where the treatment grew a lot
less than the control and again the
manual phenotyping fully bugs act and
the interesting thing is that although
your eyes cannot see it the instrument
was able to tell us there was a lot more
yellowing in the plants treated with in
this case in the salt treatment versus
the control okay so all I'm showing here
just a cup just up a group of the lines
not all of them again this 14 students
have allowed me to now phenotype 200 of
the lines of the right diversity panel
we have gone through the analysis of
84,000 images as Todd was saying very
big datasets you need to develop a
different set of skills to handle that
amount of data and I just want to finish
telling you that we are a core facility
we accept new users and whether you
already have the money to do the
experiment are thinking about getting
the money to do the experiment we are
we're happy to talk to you and to help
you
we are resource for the planet science
community and we hope you find this
useful
my colleague dr. John Trent I want me to
tell you that he has this beautiful PET
imaging system at Washington University
of San Luis is an incredible scientist
he developed heat maybe from his own is
really really amazing and
and Margaret already showed you the
power of this Technic and I'm sure
critical share some of the power of
these to me as a biochemist as a
biochemist is just so amazing to see how
the carbon that was given in the leaves
suddenly can be monitoring a life in a
plenary still life right it's just like
mind-blowing okay so my clothing is like
is this one I just want to tell you I
really believe there is the need for
more cooperation I'm very grateful to
the opportunity to be here I hope that
is a lot of opportunity for interaction
collaboration etc and I encourage you to
get very much involved in the North
American plant in the Taiping Network
this is a group of people that we are
always enthusiast about phenotyping and
about learning together and making of
these a more vibrant community in the
United States so please contact me or
any of my colleagues involved on this
and we that'll be very happy to take any
questions
[Applause]
question
and then I well we we really want um so
this is our dream okay
our dream is or not
long live Lima what are the goals of the
Chilam imaging core social is to develop
a database where we can all shoot the
data but we want to have also the tool
to allow people to analyze their data so
we really wanted to write things that
were compatible with plan TV again
because we really think an open source
software will be a much easier way to
handle things so you might both of
growth completely a new algorithm yes
the sense of are the same the images
were the exact same
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu